Лєні 32 роки
дизайнерка моди, успішна, є гроші та житло
Бракує тільки чоловіка до душі
Де ж його шукати?
На роботі? Всі колеги вже зайняті
У барах та на вечірках?
Вона таке не дуже любить.
Рятівна ідея: сайти знайомств
Цей спосіб у Німеччині обрали майже 12 мільйонів людей
Галузь стрімко розвивається
минулого року тільки у ФРН вона принесла 214 мільйонів євро
а загалом у світі – аж понад 4 мільярди
Обрати непросто
дві з половиною тисячі сервісів пропонують свої послуги
на німецькомовному ринку кохання
Звичайні побачення: коштують усього 4 євро на місяць
Знайомство через мобільний додаток, спонтанно, без жодних зобов’язань
Лєні таке не підходить
Вона реєструється в онлайн-службі знайомств
Це задоволення удесятеро дорожче - 40 євро
Лєна заповнює профіль – фото, вік, фах, хобі
І починає пошуки
П’ять чоловіків за три дні
Лєна зустрічається з ними в кав’ярнях
як зазвичай на перших побаченнях
Її серце швидко б’ється
але не від чоловіків, а від кави
Судженого серед них немає.
Тепер Лєна звертається у професійне шлюбне агентство
Коштує це 450 євро за 6 місяців
Треба відповісти на 50 запитань про себе
Сімейні психологи та складні комп’ютерні програми
підбирають кандидатів
Один з них – Лукас
Він практикант, розумний, жартівник
Коли говорить, не робить граматичних помилок
Кар’єристці Лєні це подобається
Під час зустрічі виявляється
попереду у Лукаса ще два побачення, тож він зачекає з відповіддю
Лєні слід набратися терпіння.
Але її агентство радіє
Якщо нічого не вийде, клієнт продовжить передплату
Та Лєна не втрачає надії:
кожен третій шлюб в Німечині починався зі знайомства в інтернеті